okay so listen I've been making an
effort to talk about lots of other
issues while allowing the Trump Russia
investigation to continue my thought has
been let special prosecutor Robert
Muller do his job don't get wrapped up
in every minor issue that comes up
because eventually we'll get some major
announcement or some non announcement or
Trump will be vindicated or he won't or
whatever and we can talk about event but
the last 48 hours have seen such major
news related to Trump Russia that it
would be a disservice to you as a viewer
or listener of the show not to get you
up to speed on it there are really four
sort of major stories in the last 48
hours directly related to Trump Russia
number one we've learned that the u.s.
government wiretapped Trump's former
campaign manager a campaign chairman
Paul Manafort during the campaign this
was done with secret court orders that
is a major development and it relates to
intelligence collected by authorities
connected to communications that naina
fort had with russia related to Donald
Trump's campaign now you might say oh
it's a witch hunt
Mueller's fishing no no they went to a
judge and had the wiretap approved that
means that there was enough there
already to justify a wiretapping the
campaign manager of a presidential
candidate that's major now if your Trump
or his cronies you might hear this you
say oh you've got to be going through
your communications with Donald Trump
right did I or with Paul Manafort rather
did I have a phone call with Paul
Manafort that now might be part of what
Robert Muller has access to and what you
also need to prepare yourselves for is
Donald Trump saying hey I was right
Obama did wiretap Trump Tower this has
nothing to do with Obama this is
intelligence agencies getting approval
from FISA courts if Trump was wiretapped
it's because he was on the phone with
Paul Manafort who was wiretapped and
that could be really really bad for
Donald Trump so this is absolutely major
number two and this is even bigger the
New York Times is reporting that Robert
Mulder's prosecutors
have already told Paul Manafort he's
getting indicted period the New York
Times if they are correct in their
reporting is saying the former campaign
manager to the President of the United
States is getting indicted and
interestingly CNN's Manu Raju reports
that Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
told him man affords lawyers have not
been returning phone calls for weeks we
heard a month ago that Paul Manafort was
fully cooperating and we didn't exactly
know what that meant
we now have heard his lawyers haven't
been returning phone calls for a month
that is not exactly cooperation and the
reason for this leak that Paul Mann
affords indictment is is imminent could
be to try to get manna fort out ahead of
this and cooperating with Moeller in a
different way
maybe informing on others maybe just
returning Mulder's phone calls right and
the idea being if manna fort has a
bigger fish to inform on then maybe the
looming indictment would get him to talk
but who's bigger than manna for deaths
in this I mean we're talking potentially
about reaching Trump himself the
interesting if the administration tried
to get out ahead of this to like when
Sean Spicer tried to limit Manta force
role in the campaign oh yeah who was
that guy who was just a brief stint he
didn't really we wasn't very Ventura
moans in the intern bullpen that's all
he was never really involved in anything
and remember this was all fake six
months ago right there was nothing and
we've gone from there being nothing here
two confirmed in-person meetings with
Russian lawyers for the purposes of
defeating Hillary Clinton we have an
indictment allegedly coming up but we
were led to believe from the beginning
that this was all just a fake witch-hunt
and in addition to this fired and
disgraced national security adviser
Michael Flynn now has set up a legal
defense fund to help pay for his legal
bills which have been mounting and more
than likely are going to grow even more
and it's sort of funny it's been made
clear that the Legal Defense Fund isn't
going to accept contributions from
foreign governments at this point why
not right I mean foreign money got
Michael Flint into this mess to begin
with
maybe foreign money can help get him out
by contributing to his legal defense
fund and Michael Flint actually tweeted
a link to his Legal Defense Fund
yesterday where
said Laurie and I are very grateful to
my brother Joe and sister Barbara for
creating a fund to help pay my legal
defense costs we deeply appreciate the
support of family and friends across
this nation who have touched our lives
think about how insane this is the
former national security adviser of the
United States after being forced to
resign is on Twitter asking for
donations to a Legal Defense Fund that
by the way is only receiving donations
between PayPal it almost looks like a
spoof phishing site but it's reality Pat
gotta love how he left his siblings to
make it to as if he it wasn't really his
idea no no no yeah their family his
family is helping him out
Flynn reportedly worth seven million
dollars according to one account if he's
asking for money on Twitter through
PayPal donations there has to be an
expectation that it's going to get much
much worse for him and then last part of
this story in addition to note learning
that Paul Manafort was wiretapped
in addition to learning that Paul
Manafort is reportedly about to be
indicted and that Michael Flynn is lazy
raising money on Twitter for his
legal-defense Donald Trump jr. and
Kellyanne Conway are choosing to forego
Secret Service protection now how is
this related to Trump Russia we don't
really know right the idea is if the
heat is really getting stronger and
stronger you might want to get rid of
Secret Service protection just because
it would allow you more freedom of
movement in a discreet way for what I
don't know but my sense is if you feel
that the heat is getting closer and
closer you don't necessarily want Secret
Service coordinating your every move so
the bigger trends here are what number
one it's not getting smaller it's
getting bigger with every week Trump
Russia gets bigger and number two this
is looking more and more like a federal
financial crimes investigation and it's
sort of logical Trump has many mafia
connections Trump's defenders want to
cast Robert Muller as phishing just
casting this really wide net seeing what
he comes across but the more we learn
it's clear that Robert Muller is very
organized the approach is to focus on
the finances the potential fraud money
laundering transactions
donations contributions and he's
focusing on getting people sort of at
the level of Flynn and mana fort pinned
and maybe they would turn on the really
big names how much longer could be a
long time legal experts are still saying
could be 12 to 18 months before this
really moves forward to remind you about
Watergate the Watergate burglars were
arrested in June of 1972
it took 12 months before we had evidence
of Richard Nixon's involvement and it
took more than two years until Richard
Nixon ultimately resigned so we're
already at a year and we're only now
getting close to our first indictment
this could be a very long time I
understand that these investigations
have to be slow and deliberate you want
to get the facts right you want to get
the people who are responsible indicted
and investigated and all that stuff you
want to do it properly but you're
talking about a presidential term that
only lasts four years could be up by the
time this is all through I was thinking
if Trump's gonna be booted we want to
boot him before he starts World War
three right I mean there is some sense
of urgency and time pressure here so
that's the latest and I think it's
really important to keep up with